hey folks and welcome to console crew
your weekly roundup of all of the
biggest xbox playstation and nintendo
news now it's already been a huge week
for xbox with the bethesda acquisition
going through but there are more stories
to talk about
so joining me this week as always i've
got xbox expert jordan remain
yo and playstation pro tomorrow hussein
i'm still alive despite 2020 and 2021's
efforts i am still here
you'll never stop me still alive in
spite of factors
all right let's jump in to the news
all right kicking off this week we've
got joey greco i mean tamar hussein
here to talk about cheetahs absolutely
not
i don't know who joey greco is but i
don't like the sound of it have you ever
seen the tv show cheetahs
no it's so bad and the host got stabbed
on one episode oh no i have seen she is
yeah
yes so everyone you've heard it you love
it
you've been asking for it de novo
it's on ps5 who tim who's been asking
for it
i have no idea the thing is like i was
reading this and um a british reference
here but it reminds me of shooting stars
the name of these companies like
deneuver by a dare to and i was like is
this a vic reeves joke
but that's british you know that's your
your one british joke back to town
yeah so de novo if you if you've been if
you've been playing games on a pc
for a while you're probably familiar
with it and you're paying attention to
stuff like
drm and that kind of stuff you'll be
familiar with denovo
it's got a bunch of different arms but
the relevant one for us right now is the
technology
that is yeah lucy's doing the arm thing
it's like i don't know
it's like uh ashura from usher as wrath
it's got
a lot of arms and it's trying to grab
many things and punch boulders the
boulders being cheers
um so in this situation what we have is
uh de novo is coming to playstation five
it's going to be available as a
middleware program
in in like the tools um for developers
and it effectively
offers developers an anti-cheat
kind of technology um the actual de novo
has
across all platforms two billion game
installs
which is hella game in stores um
and effectively what it does is it
it kind of allows developers to lock
down
certain areas of code which um
cheaters would look at and exploit to
do their dirty deeds on on the internet
by that i mean cheating not
okay cheating in games not cheating as
in the cheat is cheaters kind of way you
know what i'm saying
[Music]
um yeah so it's coming um it's it's
it has been effective in previous games
that has been used in
um and they say that it's gonna work
online and offline
um and apparently it will have no
negative impact on
in-game performance um and it won't make
devs lives uh
more tricky however i was gonna say they
would say that wouldn't they they would
say that
but there's a little history there
though like the only time i've ever
heard of it
has been in you know headlines for not
great reasons yeah to cover to cover our
bases
de novo works in a lot of situations
it has proven to work a lot of
developers use it
some of them don't say they use it um so
we're not doubting the
capabilities of de novo or it's anyone's
decision to put it into their game
however
they have biffed it in the past a few
times
so it was uh most notably uh or recently
it was
added to um doom eternal and
uh then got removed from doom internal
thus making it so bad it got kicked out
of hell
because it caused performance issues
with that game and it reduced like it
made the game
really unstable um and i think they just
updated it
uh or something like that um and in the
past they've had uh
uh katsira harada director of tekken 7
blamed issues with
the uh tekken 7 on de novo drm it got
dropped out of resi
iii um very quietly they're just very
quiet
they've taken it out it was like a steam
patch note there is a there is a kind of
rocky history with lenovo and games uh
at least on pc for sure on pc yeah so
initially it comes from it being seen as
a form of drm
i think we're past that now but there's
very real
possibilities that it can destabilize a
game experience
so that sounds scary but it also is kind
of on developers to make sure that if
they are implementing that they need to
ensure that they are not creating any
detrimental effects for the games that
they
are implementing them in um and as noted
by um lucy here in the notes uh
most of those cases of it being weird
have been with anti-tamper
stuff that lenovo technology that lenovo
has and antici is a different kind of
tool
so it could be that it circumvents those
issues because it's not trying to do
anti-tamper stuff
yeah i mean overall like reducing the
number of cheaters is a good thing
and a big thing that de novo does is
like increases the time it takes for
people to crack
games and so in the press release they
put out they were like oh yeah it means
that like
70 percent of a game's revenue comes in
its first two weeks so
obviously for devs and publishers you
want the time
taken to crack your game to be as long
as possible um well obviously you don't
even want your game to be correct at all
i i really hope it doesn't biff
online stuff i'm glad it's in there i
just really hope that you know
stuff's gonna be fine i can't actually
recall an issue where i think i've
come across cheaters in any multiplayer
games at least with overwatch like the
the main thing we can we come against is
people definitely using mouse and
keyboard
like i watch your kill feeds widowmaker
all those games with
nova they must be doing their job then
lucy if you're not coming across any
cheaters
i know um so yeah what do you guys think
do you think
do you think we're gonna have another
biff or do you think it's because it's
on a different platform we're gonna kind
of be okay
i mean nothing's perfect nothing's
perfect there
there could be like something wrong in
the future i think just being like out
will be fine from here on out
like nothing is going to be just fine
from here on out you can't point to any
program anywhere that just works a
hundred percent of the time
put that on uh put that on a quote
nothing will be fine for nothing
jordan 2021 the thing is as well so i
was doing like little bits of research
for getting these notes it's like
it is wild that you can buy third-party
controllers with like aimbots built in
and hacks and stuff which is
i don't know who's getting who's having
fun with that you're not only cheating
the game
but you're choosing to say
earlier this week the xbox and bethesda
deal went through
uh we actually aren't going to cover
that today because we already did we did
a little bonus episode of console crew
on tuesday
uh we'll link it somewhere so you can go
back and watch we basically analyze pete
hines and phil spencer's statements
and try and figure out just which games
are going to be xbox exclusive going
forward because they did confirm that
some
titles will be however that's not the
big xbox story this week
jordan take us through it we're getting
another
xbox game coming to steam this time it's
forza horizon 4 which is an
excellent racing game and i say that as
someone who normally just doesn't
enjoy playing racing games it's a little
bit weird because it's a
three-year-old game and it's releasing
for its full price of 60
on steam which
maybe it kind of goes back to the
episode we just had talking about the
bethesda acquisit
acquisition where we're like you know if
xbox wants to be a little cheeky they
can be like you can pay this price here
it's free
over here like they could be like it's
60 on steam or if you have
xbox game pass ultimate it's 15
a month so you can get forza horizon 4
for
four months before you pay the 60 and
try all these other games and once you
try one of the other games
we're probably gonna sink our talents
into you and you won't be able to leave
which is really what xbox wants it just
wants you to drag you into their
ecosystem making big phil sound real
evil here right yeah i mean
this is like like it's it's a good
plan like i'm not trying also you know
like the most evil company ever but like
they just want people to come in
to the game pass ultimate eco system
wasn't was willy wonka an evil person i
don't know yes so he just wanted
listen the man had sweets
he was he wasn't even wondering um he
definitely killed children he's just
sitting in his room being like we live
in a society
no it's it's the phrase ecosystem that
keeps getting me
like it's it's kind of when brands say
part of the family
and there's been a lot of the welcome to
the xbox family chat this week but it
sounds
you know sounds friendly on the surface
but really it is just business
business chat business
but no i mean what do you think about
like it
forza horizon 4 seems like a weird pick
because it's 2018
there's also like no cross progression
or cross save either so there's
a hell of microtransactions in there
though yeah so but it's doing them
really well like it's number four on
steam yeah i mean now it's recording
this it might be at a completely
different place by the time this episode
airs on
friday but forza horizon feels like a
game that you
make available to people there because
it's also a a kind of
a kind of platform where people will
people will invest in
in kind of the long term of playing that
game you know it's not a game
like gears where i mean gears is kind of
similar but it's not a game where you a
single player game where you buy it play
it and then you're done
yeah they can by putting force their
horizon on there and making it full
price they know that people will pay
that price
and then they're kind of hooked in for a
while because they know the game is good
and they'll keep coming back and playing
online and buying stuff through the
marketplace and dlc
etc etc and yeah it makes sense that
they would put that game
on the platform right now it's probably
more more
more recent releases that they could do
um
but it's you know it's a good it's a
good it's a revenue stream instead of a
revenue
i don't know say and then they can be
like oh and if you like
four is a horizon four this is the
developer making
the new fable and it's like so you play
an english car
that farts ever voiced by
john cleese i don't know i mean it does
make sense but
it does feel i mean like i was looking
at the reviews on steam and most of them
are just like
it's mixed for a start and most of it is
just people who are being
super sad that all of their progress
isn't gonna um isn't gonna carry over so
you've gotta wonder
if they must have some form of like xbox
live
gold maybe if they wanted to be playing
that game online so it's like maybe
that's just a
a a marketing issue with xbox that they
were like
yeah but you could be playing this on
your pc if you just if you just change
to
if you had game pass ultimate they would
have cross progression i think
i think it has cross progression between
the console yeah i think pc version yeah
yeah i want my anime car skins
i will if you see me on track it's going
to be with a waifu car
this week we had mario day which is
honestly like i love a bit of wordplay
add a bit of numbers in there too
march 10th mario day i love it uh
relatively quiet um
just some merch on offer um but if
you're into that
if you're into super mario i want to
celebrate his birthday it's not his
birthday but you know
his international day of celebration
we've got a compilation of all of the
best super mario trailers
up on the channel right now if you want
to take that little trip down a memory
lane we've also got until the end of the
month uh
there's not much room in my life for
them
and then the end of the the end of
mario's tyranny year is over and the
year of zelda
begins um do you i mean
i don't really have much else to say
about you know the year of mario
um other than it's kind of been nice
like i always forget that he's you know
35 years old and it's also like the 40th
i think anniversary of donkey kong this
year so a lot of anniversaries
for nintendo this year so just wanted to
kind of drop that in there before we
move on because the big
release this week on switch is apex
legends
jordan i'm going to come to you because
you are the apex fan
like we've all played i haven't
personally played on the switch just yet
um how is it cause i know you usually
play on xbox
you can play it
oh no you can play it on switch it's
it's one of those things where uh who
did the port was it panic
button yeah panic button uh
bless them for somehow some way
making a game design for xbox one and
ps4
and actually really only truly working
on these next-gen consoles like porting
something like that to switch
god bless them but at the same time this
is not
probably the way that you want to play
apex if you don't have an xbox one
ps4 pc uh series xs or
ps5 and you only play games on switch
then sure
yeah play apex on switch it works
there's no
major bugs that i've noticed so far no
major
hitching or anything like that it's just
like it it's 720p like struggling to
give you that 30 fps
and so it's like oh my god it looks
that's the thing i was afraid of and
like so for context uh last week i did a
video called
um actually evan and i did a video
together called um
you know nine improvements you want to
see on a switch pro after the bloomberg
report saying that you know
potentially it'll output in 4k when
docked and like one of the things i was
saying is that um
i wanted i want to have like that big
power increase because games like apex
and witcher
and overwatch which time you can speak
to because you um played a bunch of
overwatch on switch
it's like i don't want the switch to be
the the worst place to play
games like that because i wanted to be a
contender and it's
and it sucks that every time a
third-party port of a game like that
comes out on switch it's like
ah it's cool that it's there but the
thing that i think i would worry about
is if i were to play apex on twitch and
i get i know it's free but
cross uh platform cross play it's like
did you notice any issues with that at
all like were you getting trounced or
do you think the mmr was putting you in
with um i'll say
so far i i actually feel kind of bad
because i keep being put since it's
starting over i'm being put in like the
level 1 to 10
lobbies and so far i've only been paired
with other
switch players which i'm like people
either getting
used to the game or picking up the game
for the first time and they're playing
it on switch so
oh boy i'm decimating them so far but
i'm sure i'll get to higher rankings at
some point
it was good because i know in overwatch
like you can't play comp unless you
are like level 25 i think so i wonder if
apex has a similar thing where like
it'll lock you off and just
yeah you have to be level 10 to actually
get into ranked mode so
yeah but like i jumped into my first
match and
i won easily like both of my teammates
dropped at the start so i'm like i'm by
myself
and i still won but i think that's more
so just the fact that i have
35 days worth of time and you know why
don't you
because all those switch players aren't
shooting people they're trying to jump
on each other's heads
it's not how you get kills lads that's
not how it was
trying to play this game in handheld
mode like
don't try to have a pro controller have
the enhanced
uh third-party controller that has like
the bumpers on the back have some form
of controller trying to play this game
and handheld mode is rough oh i would
i would just like to clarify for the
nintendo fans that was
a joke um i am a nintendo fan
um die hard nintendo fan please do not
come for me
that was a joke
and one of you relax
i was gonna think so i know in overwatch
they put in motion controls which was a
baffling decision because oh it's an
apex too lucy it's an apex suit you can
move around to like aim your gun in
apex legends and i'm like yeah we're
we're going to have to disagree
we're definitely done yeah i mean
playing breath of the wild it's like
uh i had the motion control switched on
for aiming
and i just i've never switched off
anything faster so
interesting design choice i'm bummed
that it's not you know
a better place a bad port for the game
but
it's good that's there and it is free so
yeah if you had to pay for this i'd be
like no no stay away but it's also 25
kicks
and they say that to like start the
download they advise that you have 30
gigabytes free so like i
i needed a micro yeah uh sd card just to
make room for it on my switch so we're
trying out a new thing and at the end of
every episode we're gonna be going
through the big releases for consoles
that week so this week like we said we
had apex legends on switch
we've got the watchdogs legion
multiplayer mode which finally
so excited i i
think the ship has sailed personally i
didn't really even enjoy watchdogs
multiplayer in general but you know sit
in the uk
feel a bit homesick so give it a go more
importantly though you've got the crash
bandicoot
uh next gen upgrade as well as like dlc
and stuff it is the anniversary crashed
this year
so hopefully we're gonna see more crash
this year and
most most importantly the next gen
uh xbox series x slash s update
for overwatch is out 120 frames per
second
but not on playstation 5. so
maybe we'll be able to talk about that
one next week
time to move over to xbox i was going to
say time to start a smith account
boys let's go
thank you for watching this week's
episode of console crew i
can find me on twitter at lisa james
games tam i'm at tamor h
jordan i am at jm remain and we'll see
you next week
if you're into super mario i want to
celebrate his birthday it's not his
birthday but you know his international
day of celebration
we've got a compilation of all of the
best super mario trailers up on the
channel right now
if you want to take that little trip
down a memory lane um
it's awesome also do what i did and
celebrate it by eating hella mushrooms
you know what i'm saying
i am in the sky right now lads
oh god are we allowed to do that
i was just about to ask them like can we
leave that in
don't take do drugs on drugs that was a
joke for
uh